est très dilué les lettrés rôle sens
mais il faut plus de plus de contraste
vous prenez une vieille dame bientôt
bicentenaire un célèbre designer un
décor ancestral
un vrai tour demain et vous obtenez la
nouvelle collection de la faïencerie de
gien allure c'est son nom porte la
signature de l'artiste olivier gagnère
on a composé de nouveau blason fait de
nouvelles terres moiry totalement
imaginaire et ça a été le mélange est de
le mêler de le faire une interférence
avec un autre décor floral qui est une
grande des grandes spécificités de deux
chiens qui est le décor du littoral et
ce n'est pas tout ce nouveau décor
inclut aussi les petits points de la
collection pontault chou est le chaînon
symbolique qui relie les éléments les
uns aux autres un travail technique
méticuleux de superpositions et de
retranscription le projet d'olivier
gagnaire ce et est développé sous forme
de planches de rohff que nous avons mis
après en forme à partir de fichiers
informatiques en très haute qualité
nous avons fait imprimer à partir de nos
plaques de cuivre les documents
d'archivés et puis nous les avons
retouché et recomposé pour avoir des
fichiers de traîtresse définition dans
l'usiné les premières pièces sont en
fabrication
si une partie des décors et réalisé en
chrome os à partir de décalcomanies
certains éléments sont peints à la main
comme il y a deux siècles faut bien
suivre deux
lance le relief de lens avec le pinceau
éviter trop de coups de pinceau parce
que sinon à la cuisson ça se voit puis
c'est une nouvelle couleur qu'on a
jamais
faites ce nouveau service présenté en
exclusivité aux états unis ne sera
commercialisé qu'en septembre la
faïencerie de js faire bien écrire une
nouvelle page à son histoire